je vais vous dire attendez là
bizarrement visage on attendait pas
laisser mon fils il décide de tenir biz
a bizarrement si vous voulez vous
combattez la souffrance animale
sauf que tout l'abattage rituel religion
qu'elle soit qui le pratiquent
on vous entend jamais pas d'accord donc
non la loue pour l'aïd-el-kebir quand il
ya des millions de noms qui sont égorgés
comme par hasard vous aimez le
champignon on vous entend pas voilà un
que quand vous avez des concerts ou des
combats contre tous des combats sélectif
en fonction de votre néologie politique
par ailleurs tarif vous savez madame
veut que je lui répondais je vous
répondrai tout de suite que c'est les
boucheries halal ou casher ça vous pose
pas de 6,6 mds de tous les âges et leur
charisme sept cantons les attaques tout
que ça merci quelle qu'elle soit mais
moi aussi c'est bon le plaidoyer
s'il vous plaît monsieur plairait c'est
le final on l'appelle le rappeur
quelqu'un je fais un lien entre le
préciser si je fais un lien vers le
précédent un sujet celui là c'est c'est
la question qui consiste à dire 'est-ce
qu'on impose ses choix autrui c'est ça
c'est ça le vrai sujet est ce qu'on
n'aime pas ces choix de tri quand on
veut se balader à poil
la réponse est non on va dans un centre
de naturisme fermé donc et on rencontre
effectivement ceux qui ont envie de se
balader à poil comme comme quand vous en
avez envie
est ce que on va porter atteinte aux
agriculteurs sur ne veut plus manger de
viande de la réponse est non on ne mange
plus de viande et si on est de plus en
plus nombreux à ne pas en manger parce
que effectuant pour la santé publique
qu'est ce qu'il ya ça veut pas dire ça
veut pas dire qu'on est contre
intentions séditieuses très bien elle a
changé d'avis sur l'avion de l'avion
très beau vous êtes d'accord avc tout de
suite dit fait un rapt a raccourci ses
fans il est beau il est élégant et
beaucoup de bien réveillez pas les
fioles et jean loubon soir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes fan de l'émission
paris alors oui j'essaie de suivre
excusez mon possible
et j'aime beaucoup madame laurence
sailly à la partie focalisé sur très
sensée et c'est vraiment une femme
bianchi a beaucoup de classe ne met pas
monsieur vous connaître son message de
votre idole sur accueil mitigé avec tapé
sur le clavier
c'est un honneur mais maintenant ces
deux époques informations des photos
sous secteur et ça c'est comme ça tous
les gens de droite et défendez avec ses
hôtes chirac était ingrate à michel
hunault gens nous faisait jean le
morizet vous êtes scandalisés par ce que
je viens de dire cynthia oui oui c'est
honteux c'est honteux moitié s'est
étirée quand j'entendais des bêtises
pareilles
il nous faut un tort considérable ces
temps là vous votre e collectivités s'y
trouvait mais j'avais découvert à nu a
fait quatre mois de coup de vent il vous
faut pas faire trop non mais la viande
ainsi essentiel dans l'alimentation font
jour comme des cochons mais les cochons
la nage en effet demandé de tout la
fosse on écrit culture de qualité cette
union nous envient madame tout le monde
des produits les produits phyto si vous
mettez pas sur l'agriculture jeudi mais
si les poulets les prix du lait écoutez
des produits phyto moi je viens des
agriculteurs la moitié des semaines je
savais que si on n'avait pas de produits
phyto pour mettre au sol et sur les sur
les cultures et on ne mangerait pas
excitant mais oui mais tu connais pas
c'est par il va montrer les liens
commerciaux
et c'est la vérité
non mais c'est la vérité est ce qu'il y
a qu'a les produits ces jeunes joueurs
de karim khan qu'est ce qui se passe n'a
eu bernard vaut prendre ma place je
laisse alors allez-y changer de place à
la barbarie qu'a voulu mais aussi des
moules et c'est pas le jury mettez-vous
la famille carrier ça vous ça vous
dérange pas si je m'assois sinon vous
n'êtes pas très contente d'accord juste
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi l'agriculture bio et écolo et
bénéfique pour l'écologiste cécile
chicault beltrame à cyril alors faire un
podium et 200 m
mais en plus arrivés ou non mais l'amour
c'est l'amour à l'aîné alors j'aimerais
juste tu veux pas passer au payant plus
complet je crois que c'est une émission
sérieuse mais vous les impôts très grave
avec jean louis jean loup s'il vous
plaît jean linnhoff sept éleveurs
producteurs de viande bovine abrogeant
si oui en quoi se nourrir justin trudeau
avait fini parce que je suis là pour
nourrir sa voix il est marié oui depuis
très longtemps avant pour nous pousser
les gens essaient de les boucher qui
sont attaqués par ces bons centres
weygand là un cac qui les sites d'agc
fait telle chose abattoirs sur les
salaires mais vous vous faites du bio
jean loup est ce que vous pouvez nous
montrer comment voilà oui coûter mais
c'est pas compliqué nous les les bétons
on vit avec tout le temps qu'on sent le
tube comme il faut mon dieu mais il ya
un animal ils sont nourris au point et
qu'on leur faire un complément en fait
vous tournez dans ce sens là il ya un
ananas qui sort directement nom s'est
passé c'est pour ça faut expliquer c'est
pas compliqué hein
le fonds ne fait bien mais ça suffit pas
il faut leur donner incompétente pour
moi mais j en grèce et au procès j'ai
amené mon malaxeur que j'ai bricolé avec
un oui mais oui mais de la wayne du blé
tout ça et moi de récupérer des les
invendus de légumes lac
bah écoutez ça se met là dedans voyez
ouais ben laden et après ils patates et
apprécions garni ou hétéro oui c'est
d'appuyer pipe cible aie aie un tuyau et
ça envoie énormément
[Musique]
[Rires]
elle cherchait à vous tous merci